speak to the men out there and give them
some advice on how to find these genuine
women don't put up with women's [ __ ]
okay definitely agree with that what
else find who has integrity and who
doesn't so integrity in women are two
things that don't generally go together
very well in our experience no they
don't right because
women are only as loyal as their options
generally speaking and this is where you
try to use your discernment to figure
that out right i'm talking to you guys
as younger men who are coming in and
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there
some of these women are [ __ ] crazy do
you have any kids michelle i think you
have two right yes i do i have two girls
if one of your girls brought home a guy
that killed like i don't know a skunk or
a cat or something like that in his
backyard and she told you about it like
what would you think of that would you
be like oh yeah you should marry him or
would you tell her to get rid of the guy
no i'd be like why didn't you do it
yourself
okay michelle
okay no no
so now we know what we're dealing with